thought you were leaving without saying
goodbye did you thanks Hagrid
I'm with you beloved Scottish actor
Robbie Coltrane has died he was 72.
[Music]
Reports say Robbie who's known for his
role as rubius Hagrid in Harry Potter
franchise died at a hospital near his
home in larbert Scotland after battling
health issues over the last two years
it's changing out there
just like last time
storm coming Ari
we'd all best be ready when she does JK
Rowling author of the Harry Potter book
series took to Twitter with an emotional
tribute quote I'll never know anyone
remotely like Robbie again he was an
incredible Talent a complete one-off and
I was beyond fortunate to know him work
with him and laugh my head off with him
I send my love and deepest condolences
to his family above all his children
you're a wizard Harry
I'm a what Daniel Radcliffe also
remembered the actor quote Robbie was
one of the funniest people I've ever met
I've especially fond memories of him
keeping our spirits up on Prisoner of
Azkaban I feel incredibly lucky that I
got to meet and work with him and very
sad that he's passed the Harry Potter
star ended his tribute calling Robbie an
incredible actor and lovely man hello
there friends
see you've met our young Mr Potter
oh right there hurry
I've got to say it's bigger than Bond
and I thought Bond was pretty outrageous
yeah my career is going to go down the
tubes now you can tell Emma Watson paint
tribute 2 calling Robbie the most fun
Uncle I've ever had she also vowed if I
ever get to be so kind as you were to me
on a film set I promise I'll do it in
your name and memory and yet a thing of
a spell that our Hermione can do
come here
Robbie starred in many projects across
TV and film including UK TV series
cracker and big screen movies like
GoldenEye and oceans 12. hey maybe
that's why I've been feeling so warm
recently
[Laughter]
Robbie also acted alongside Elijah Wood
in 1993's The Adventures of Huck Finn
and E.T was on set they wanted some sort
of
International Superstar to sort of get
the budget
so that was the Natural Choice in New
York I get recognized because New
Yorkers go to the movies a lot
um outside New York they tend to kind of
look at you and they can't remember if
you're the guy who was threw up at their
uncle's birthday party or if you're the
guy that used to clear the pool or
something but they know you it's very
funny because they kind of go
but they don't know you know they don't
recognize you enough to come up and say
hi or whatever it's very funny and years
later he landed the part of Hagrid a
character adored by fans around the
world especially Robbie's family
foreign
JK Rowling's always she said in print
she wanted me to play Hagrid and that
was it so I got a lot of pressure from
my children they said well you've got to
do it dad or you're dead meat the last
time fans saw Robbie on screen was for
HBO's return to Hogwarts a 20th
anniversary special where he left
viewers with an emotional message the
legacy of the movies is that my
children's generation will show them to
their children so you could be watching
50 years time easy
I'll not be here sadly don't you think
on it for one minute but Hagrid will
yes
[Music]